why anime you've never watched a movie i
was i was like i'm just gonna watch
anime i watched it as a kid growing up i
watched naruto i watched dragon ball z
kai
and uh but i never watched anything else
i had like a couple shonen jump yeah um
but nothing hardcore like one piece two
uh and then when i applied for the jet
program i was like because that's where
i pivoted after the self-help thing i
was like i'll do a jet program okay my
mom won't see that
and i was like okay chris broad videos
and what's a good anime i looked it up
and i was like okay sort out online
oh
i think it's very good at introducing
people to anime i will say that it's a
good gateway good gateway i mean it is
like it it has all the tropes you will
find in anime yeah yeah it gets you
ready for it crossfield of dreams song
is also good the one where it's like the
the field yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and i'm like and it's like spy kids 3d
so it's like i want to be you die in the
game you die in real life
you know and it's a lot of tropes that i
know and i was like i'm all on board up
until the main villain was holding the
like main protagonist girl yeah and like
like sexually assaulting her oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i was like maybe i should find a new one
i stuck it out all the way through the
gun series too oh gun gale yeah yeah i
gave it a good i watched all the guys
shot online as i like to call it yeah
literally just ass shots and then
shaking finally with the sniper goes
yeah yeah apparently it gets better no
like recently it's gotten better it does
no it does no i've heard i've heard it's
good now okay like
as much as like clown on sword arts
online it's just kind of like my junk
food i've actually i realized this
recently i've watched every
anime of sword art online that's been
produced so far really yeah i don't know
why how or why i did this to myself but
i did and the latest season alicization
i i generally think is a lot of fun
would i call it good i don't know it's
kind of like fun in american culture a
lot of the times people have like a
sitcom that they just watch on repeat
it's like their comfort sitcom and it's
it's well it's like it's friends it's
hemium it's big bang theory if you have
no taste and it's just their show and
like that's what sort of it is you know
it's just easy
it doesn't surprise you too much bottom
line is the big bang theory of anime
yeah
honestly yeah but honestly
you finished it online then what did you
watch well then i wanted to be cultured
right so i looked up what the best anime
were
and i tried to watch those okay so like
full metal alchemist brotherhood right
couldn't get through it
i i couldn't get through it did did you
eventually get through it no so long
uh hunter hunter what
it was so long connor it was oh it's 64
episodes yeah but by episode like 35
it's mostly like recap and talking and
and fighting brotherhood yeah
brotherhood why did we watch the same
show it's so slow it's a lot of
recapping it's a lot of it's not it's
not well-paced i i haven't seen in a
long time so i can't you are the only
person i've ever met who has started
brotherhood and hasn't finished that's
that's like blasphemous you know what's
[ __ ] up too i love silver spoon
what's [ __ ] up about where the [ __ ]
did that come from that's a good show
director
same director yeah in it but it's like
nothing to do with it's clearly the less
popular of the shows that she's made
nobody talks about silverspoon yeah i
love silversmith though
like two totally different shows yeah to
be fair your favorite anime uh that you
told me about your thing was a huge
surprise like the fact that your
favorite anime is welcome to the nhk
yeah says like already a lot
yeah because what i did is like you go
through the annie list like top hundred
yeah and like i gave at least every big
show like an episode or two right right
and and i was either like okay i don't
vibe with this i don't [ __ ] with this
and i don't subscribe to the
dude you just gotta watch till episode
77 i agree i agree i don't i don't buy
that it's like okay if it hasn't pulled
me out every one piece fan right
it's like if i haven't if i haven't like
gotten into it then i my time is more
valuable than subscribing to 70 episodes
to enjoy something i can just enjoy
something off episode one and that's
great yeah of course uh and so i try
them all and then you do what you
normally do which is ask other people
and so i asked will neff do you guys
know well neff no he's like another
streamer
the name sounds familiar yeah he's he's
a he's a pretty successful streamer he's
a super sweet guy and like one of the
greatest entertainers i think in the
space
uh and he's a huge weeb right right and
he's an older guy and he's like yeah you
got to watch welcome to the nhk man like
it's a little horny but it's like it's
it's perfect it's like you're ever
feeling lonely i'm like
that's all my boxes
and i watched it and it's so good it's
very yeah yeah it's it's incredible i
haven't actually watched that one really
yeah i've been putting it off
it is i think like
the worst first anime if you've never
watched it but i think you need to be in
the right headspace to watch it it's
it's it's not about happy anime no it's
about being like a neat right yeah yeah
yeah
it's
like where i found out about like the
term of hikikomori you know that's
literally from welcome to the nhk
um but yeah it's like
very real depressingly real a lot of
times
um so it's not something you watch to be
happy it's like something you watch to
just
feel i don't know i don't know what the
right word it's like obviously
like it's a great show and it's like you
learn a lot from it and it's very real
but it's not something it's not
entertainment yeah well i think that's
exactly what i i switched because in
senior year of college like this is also
like kind of right when it started and i
was watching anime right my girlfriend
and i broke up because i caught her
cheating on me right and i made a
visceral decision i literally was like i
am going to try to cry more because i'm
not like a guy who cries a lot right
when i watch shows yeah right which is
like a literal shift in how you like try
to process them yeah and so then i like
i tried to do it first but i was like
okay i'll watch your line april
just like
[Music]
i was like that made me cry but i was
like am i crying because it's like good
and making me feel or is it because it's
emotionally manipulative and they make
you attach to a character and they play
the sad song at the sad time when you're
supposed to cry i don't know i totally
get what you mean where there's like two
different types of crying where there
are some shows which you cry you just
you don't even know why you're crying
yeah you feel like a [ __ ] somewhere
in there yeah you feel like a dog there
where like you have like the right
triggers and then it just like triggers
your tears and you're like i don't know
what i'm crying it's just no silver
spoon for me really you're not supposed
to cry at that necessarily but at a
certain point like i was doing the
festival and i was like it's so
beautiful
and i was like that's why it was one of
my favorite shows as opposed to like a
show that's like you know the classics
that like you're gonna cry like the like
the cry face like alejandra and stuff
like that right we have planned this for
you to tear up yeah which i don't i
think that's that's more bs yeah so
that's why i love welcome to nhk because
it makes you feel so much yeah it's like
full of my luck in this brotherhood well
towards the end
i am a homunculus i am not a real person
i'm not going to cry get over the fight
you got 30 episodes you did not get
thirty episodes in india i did i got i
got all the way to a point where they
were in some like white universe and it
was like blondie with the [ __ ]
alfalfa hair and he was talking to
himself isn't that near the [ __ ] end
it was close that's pretty close what
the [ __ ] i remember and then i was like
no spoilers god hasn't seen it yet
no i've never seen how are you on this
podcast
that's what i'm saying
okay yeah you got further than me wait
how can you how are you calling him out
for not watching it when you haven't
[ __ ] finished it because i don't have
a podcast called trash days
in a 15-year career fresh taste i'm not
anime
yeah i mean like uh i mean it's just
like it's just one of those shows where
god has to explain it for the night i
haven't explained everything i don't
know i don't don't explain i don't want
to [ __ ] hear it i'm just going to
think of you less for having seen of all
of sword art online and not
posted about watching every season not
even like people who like sort of online
watch all seasons
at this point it's just going to be like
the last anime i ever watched like 90
years old on my deathbed i'm going to be
like now's the time
to experience brotherhood and then your
soul fades before the final episode i'm
getting 30 episodes
i think maybe if i retried it because it
was an early it was an early show like i
sucked through all of them were you
killed by the hype of like hearing about
the show yeah because it was listed as
like one of the best okay yeah it's the
goat i don't think it is i don't think
it is what i don't think it's the i
don't think it's what you think of some
hyped anime that actually like meets the
hype then or meet the representation
madoka magicka hell yeah that shows
that it's why are you like that's a good
show it's a great race
i don't think so no good
i've seen the movie soon
promise neverland season one
yeah
season one i think is amazing it's like
a show that if i told someone to watch
it's like they'd be like yeah that was
great i just death
fathom code yes [ __ ] it up
why can't you fathom that people [ __ ]
things up all the time because it was
just literally like just follow the
blueprint because they're literally like
the fourth high school literally just
follow what is happening and then they
were like
like the manga was so successful and the
fan base was so big so that you'd think
there'd be like massive pressure to be
like all right we got to deliver to the
fans and then they're like i know what
they're like a powerpoint presentation
for the last episode skipped and then
everything they skipped
like the one piece anime people would
like they i think that they'd be riots
in japan i think people would actually
would like quit jobs they also do the
opposite where they just extend it for
three thousand episodes
yeah yeah they're like we don't have
enough money why is there no in between
why do we have to extend it a million
times and then why can't you just follow
the manga another time recap syndrome
whatever if it's the fourth highest
selling market why would the [ __ ] would
you not just stick to the market
honestly i i don't know i don't have an
explanation because they [ __ ] killed
it on season one and all they need to do
was just do more of that
and then they just didn't i don't know
maybe they wanted to finish it in two
seasons but i don't know why they would
because it's like the fourth yeah i
don't know i think i think it's always
down to like probably rush timelines and
some person above you who tells you to
do things and you have to do them but i
always just assumed that if you were the
you're a studio right it must be a
[ __ ] blessing getting a show that you
could make like 10 seasons of because
you get well no because you don't have
guaranteed funding for the those seasons
because like then you end up with
situations where it's like you have a
show that's great and then it's never
finished
yeah yeah yeah and then that's like an
equally bad fate to die from yeah what
was the uh was the first show you
watched where you had that cruel
realization that sometimes
very often anime it just doesn't end or
they just stop making it or the mind
dude i watched um i watched devil's a
part-timer oh yeah like five years ago i
was like dude this is hilarious and i
was like season two and then you find
like like the threads being like is
there a season two is there a season two
and i was like no actually there is
nothing yeah i know i heard it it's
actually airing next season i'm hyped on
that because that show was really funny
and i liked it a lot yeah i wonder if it
it'll be as funny as i remember because
i watched it like five six years also i
watch it dubbed as well
dub was really really good for that uh
that series so i don't know if i will it
will i watch the
yeah yeah yeah i feel like when it's
such a comedic timing show having good
voice acting in english definitely helps
i appreciate the jokes more as an
english person yeah i mean i feel like
especially with comedy shows and comedy
anime you my favorite comedy anime are
all ones that have amazing dubs
huh panty stalking using aunties
no because i generally don't go to anime
for comedy because i think 99 of comedy
animes aren't funny yeah yeah that is
very true that is true it's rare i find
a good comedy anime yeah a lot of them
are like comedy
like what's the one that everyone talks
about that's been long psyche
is that it
that that show sucked you know one of
the [ __ ]
looks like holy [ __ ] sakamoto no that
one's fun i think that's pretty funny
sounds like a ligma though
yeah
yeah
that's that's like kind of uh how do you
describe sacramento it's more like mr
bean
kind of in a way it's very slapstick oh
it's physical comedy it's yeah very
important it's like if mr bean was a
giga chad right yeah
that would be i would love to see the
live action of mr bean just yoked
is that johnny england yeah